well speaking of sports yes our next
guest has been called the quarterback
whisperer bruce arians was an nfl coach
for 29 years twice named ap coach of the
year he's coached five pro bowl
quarterbacks including peyton manning
and tom brady and in the 2020 season he
led tom brady and the tampa bay
buccaneers to a super bowl championship
now for the first time arians is sharing
details on his 2016 hospitalization for
a heart issue that he says was his
wake-up call in march aryan stepped away
from coaching and joined the buccaneers
front office he joins us for his first
broadcast tv interview since that
announcement good morning coach can i
still call you coach that's my job
so
what made you step away from the
sideline
it was a it wasn't a hard decision for
me um
i knew it was time and you know it's
time
uh in life for certain things and for me
it was a transition
i wanted to have secession
it was very important for me that one of
my guys took over
and after watching the hiring cycle i
wasn't real happy
all right so i wanted to make sure that
uh that todd bowles got this job what do
you mean by that are you talking about
the african-american coaches yes
opportunities yes coach and um
just who was getting the jobs yeah and
um
so i wanted to
and ownership was all in i had talked to
jason light we we'd already been talking
about this for a while
and once tom brady decided he was coming
back it's free it was a no-brainer
before we move on um you've always been
a coach that incorporated women um
coaches of color you wanted to make sure
that there was opportunity for everybody
why did you feel like that was um an
issue of importance throughout your
career
yeah i think nate for me
not being able to get a
be a head coach till i was 60.
you know we won super bowl 43 i didn't
even get a call
and it's like okay
i want to make sure when qualified
people
get an opportunity
and make open the doors
for them um especially women yeah i mean
i've known women coaches since the 90s
of course all right the door had to be
open
no before you were coming last year when
this just my mic sounded you've got a
speaker
hello you're always loud
but when when tampa bay was going
through some kirklands i was saying the
nate what is what is he like he goes
coach aryans is cool he doesn't bs he's
a he's a sharp dresser and he calls it
as he sees it that was your reputation
and so i'm wondering do you miss the day
today of that
no i i'm so lucky that uh i'm still
involved i'm on the field every day i
travel with the team you still do that i
found out i have to go to the press box
with practice against tennessee last
week and i'm cussing out to run the rest
and they throw a flag on me he said
you're not the head coach anymore i said
okay i'm going to the press okay my bad
i'm going i'm leaving
but yeah i'm gonna deal with the team
every day and uh so i've got the best of
both worlds tom brady coming to the team
take us behind the scenes you know
sharing is caring so please let us know
how that conversation went because it
was such a cinderella story and it
shocked it shocked the sports world yes
it did well it shocked me that he was
ever leaving new england yeah and uh
then when you're looking at drew brees
phil rivers and tom brady all becoming a
free agency no way yeah you know so you
got to do your due diligence we did our
homework i can really still play yeah
all right and uh lo and behold
we're on the phone
and uh he's
he's he's interviewing me he already
knows everything about the team he's
done his homework thomas tom is
relentless just like peyton was yeah and
he gets his homework done so
it just we hit it off and uh
we got lucky yeah so what is your role
as coach what does it become we were
talking about the psychology of sports
you know guys fail they've got to play
the next uh the next snap and you're
known as the quarterback whisperer so
what what is your approach to getting
the best out of the people you're
working with i think the biggest word is
trust you know you have to have the
trust of people you're working with and
a quarterback for me has to be like one
of my sons
we have to have a dialogue that there's
no bs yeah don't don't tell me what you
thought you saw what'd you see right
let's let's so we can work on this and
and get better and i think
in any business
you have to have a trust within your
organization and your you guys trust
each other that's why you put such a
great show on is it a little yeah
each other we do but i mean you're
sitting here looking very dapper looking
very healthy but you're you were here to
talk about your health scare what
happened to you
2017 we played the vikings
um looking at me
did not go very well right
middle of the night
you never want to wake your wife up at
three in the morning
tap her on the shoulder what's better we
need to go to the hospital chest pains
and um it was a scare it woke you up it
woke me up and uh that's right i found
out then i had to get a coach
for my health
and uh i remember that i was very
fortunate
bad cholesterol and stress is a silent
killer yeah was it a heart attack you
were it was no i thought it was but it
was it was luckily it wasn't and um
but i found out then i needed to diet
exercise medication
got a doctor got my team together
for my health and um
i was very very fortunate was it hard
all the things are you doing all the
right things all those things i lost 40
pounds last year and uh so like was
doing everything i'm supposed to be
doing was it hard to communicate that to
your team because coach you know in this
business and you know what happens in
football i like to say parallel society
we have these egos and we're supposed to
be superheroes and we're supposed to be
tough yeah and was it hard to go in
there and say guys um i'm weak in these
areas yeah
it's hurting me yeah i miss monday first
time everybody what what's going on
you got to be honest with your guys yeah
they know so i told them what was going
on um
got great guy got great care yeah you
know and uh
but i urge
anybody especially people in stressful
situations stressful jobs get your
cholesterol check your bad cholesterol
is something you have to take care of
yeah where was tom great advice he
wasn't in camp for the first 11 days
where was he coach oh it was very
personal very personal and uh i mean
tom's 45 times 45
you don't treat him like a 25 year old
yeah he's dealing with a lot of things
and uh that's what tom said he said i'm
44 i got a lot of going on yeah
and and we appreciate that you know
that's what makes him so special uh gave
the young quarterbacks a chance to get a
lot of reps and he came back and we
didn't but he's fine he is great and uh
all right coach don't be sneaking down
to that sideline all right no i can't
stay up in that booth i have to brother
i appreciate it thank you for being here
glad you're in good health today
thank you thank you very much